okay so moonlight is now over and the
series closes out with a big post credit
scene that could tease some major things
for the future whilst also potentially
robbing our characters of the happy
ending that they got together the
episode follows mark spectre and stephen
grant as they learn and live together in
harmony and finally become the ying to
each other's yang in the field of reeds
mark could potentially have an eternity
of paradise ahead of him but he forgoes
this in order to rescue stephen placing
his heart into stephen's hand he finally
frees him and after osiris opens up the
gates they're able to return to the
surface and the pair make a deal with
konshu to help him out one last time and
in doing so they'll finally be free
everything seems groovy baby but big
bird ends up betraying them in the end
and we're introduced to his new avatar
aka jake lockley
thing is this is the extra personality
inside mark that has been teased
throughout the season and it very much
sets up an even bigger bad in both him
and conscious so what the hell's going
on well throughout this video we're
going to be breaking it all down and
going over what we think the ending is
about if you enjoyed the video then
please hit the thumbs up button and also
don't forget to subscribe for videos
like this every day without the way
thanks for clicking this now let's get
into moon knight okay so the first thing
i want to touch upon is probably going
to make people hate me as it's my
interpretation of the ending but i
promise we'll go through what's more
likely to be happening later on in the
vid now just backtracking to the ending
in his final exchange with konchu mark
refuses to kill harrow who has just had
omit placed within him he tells him you
want them dead
[Music]
do it yourself
so hey i mean he did have to get an
avatar i suppose this is because as we
learned konchu isn't really able to
affect the real world and though he can
throw some bins about he can't actually
kill people at this point mark and
stephen are released and they almost
immediately travel into the hospital
illusion that the pair built in their
minds after breaking the fantasy they
return home and wake up in bed with a
sort of replay of the first episode
however this time there are two goldfish
inside the tank living in harmony
showing how they've learned to live
together now unpopular opinion time but
i actually think this is still a fantasy
why i believe that is is because they go
from the pyramid to the hospital to the
bed almost instantaneously it's like
mark and stephen beat harrow fall back
and then wake up in bed almost like
they've been transported there
immediately they also say
i can't believe it worked
which makes me think this moment happens
straight away from when they're released
now the fact that the wrangler is tied
to the bed and someone has been out and
bought the goldfish without them knowing
makes me believe that jake would have
done this and that he may have taken
over the moment they were released i
kind of feel like the pair might
actually be trapped in a fantasy whilst
jake is out in the real world and these
quick jumps from cairo to the hospital
to the bedroom with the new stuff in
shows it's all in mark and steven's head
again controversial and i know from just
bringing it up on the last video that
some people hate me and just wish i'd
shut the [ __ ] up which is a fair comment
now the more standard way to interpret
this is exactly how it's presented and
that they end up back in london either
way it still sort of leads us to the
same conclusion which we get in the
post-credits scene mine is just a bit
more of a head trip
meet my friend jake lockley
now in this scene konju is very much
getting jake to do what he wanted mark
ii he is finally killing amit however it
has demo repercussions beyond this
because all of the eniad were killed and
the gods not having any power at the
moment was showcased by the fact that
can't you turn the sky tonight without
anyone being like hey you can't do that
now in case you haven't read the comics
they paint punch you out more as the
villain the further into things you get
the jeff lemire run revealed that he'd
been watching over mark since he was a
child and that he deliberately fractured
his mind so that he could take over it
is possible that he even killed his
brother in order to break him further
and this is why we saw an omen outside
the cave that looked like him konchu is
a bad guy hell bent on ruling like any
of the other gods and with them out the
way in the any ad he can now do what he
wants amit is the last one who's still
inside a person and this is why he sends
his best man jake to collect him from
the hospital the hospital is called
sankowitz and it's named after the
artist bill who's done lots of moonlight
work much in the same way that the
series urban with harrow getting ready
with a glass of water and so on here we
see him with a cup of coffee that he
knocks over before he's taken out he
doesn't have his cane and due to the
years of walking on broken glass he is
wheelchair bound as jake wheels him out
we see several dead orderlies and he
takes him to a limo with consu in the
back and with the source material jake
was a cab driver so this is kind of in
line with that they have changed things
up as steven grant was a millionaire
playboy whereas in the show he's more of
a bumbling but lovable fool jake was
never really an assassin in the comics
and he was more just someone who kept
their ears to the street gathered intel
and kept a collection of sources like
crawley who pointed him in the right
direction i think it's important to bear
in mind as it makes it more difficult to
say where things are gonna go and
they've also switched up some of his
character traits for example the guy
speaks spanish showing a distinct
difference between him mark and also
stephen stephen was a cockney so i love
the way they all have their own kind of
voices now we did theorize throughout
the series that there were accent
changes that hinted towards him but i
would be happy to have those cast to the
side and just have him speaking spanish
because it sounds badass
[Music]
and there were of course hints towards
him with the date in episode 1 being
organized by someone who clearly wasn't
mark due to his marriage it was also the
fight in episode 3 which ended in a
bloodbath
sarcophagus in the hospital and when he
got the upper hand with harrow because
of mark not really wanting to kill i
kind of feel like he was in the cupcake
band too and that's why everyone got
[ __ ] up badly anyway he throws harrow
in the back kicks his chair out the way
and goes and sits in the front this limo
calls back to the comics as it was mr
knight's ride and even the license plate
is taken from the source material gonchu
also appears in a suit which is a nice
little carryover from him in that run
konju says
mark spector truly believed that after
he and i parted ways i wanted his wife
to be my avatar when he has no idea how
troubled he truly is now turns out that
mark and stephen are completely unaware
of jay and i think going forward they'll
start to find the bodies left in the
wake of jack and konchu's killing spree
the god is now clearly gonna be after it
all and with jake at his side he's
almost gonna be unstoppable this is
because mark and steven won't be in
control when he is and it's unlikely
that layla would ever want to kill the
man she loves whose body jake inherits
it's a really cool ending and we cut to
several iconic locations in london as
the pair drive out huge shout out to
mattbaker on youtube for pointing out
that you can catch the mask which has
two crescent moons on it you can also
see the moon in the sky signaling an
almost gangster-like dominion that's now
being brought to london i love the idea
going forward that mark steven and jake
are the heroes and villains and it's
such a great idea throughout the season
we've had mark and stephen going back
and forth with each other through
mirrors and we also get our first look
at jake and juan however whereas with
the other two they'd see the reflection
of their opposite when they looked in
one here only he stares back showing
he's in complete control as of now we
haven't had a second season announced
but it definitely feels like the type of
show that deserves one all the gods will
be scrambling for new avatars but konchu
could prop himself up at the top he's
still angry about being trapped in the
statue and will do whatever he can to
make sure they don't get back into
positions of power as talked about
earlier i'd love to reveal that mark and
stephen were all just trapped in a
fantasy and that jake was in control we
know this show can pull a rug from under
you in a second and i'd love to see a
battle in their minds as they all viper
control now we also have blade and dane
whitman on the other side of london who
i think would be great characters to
kind of bleed into moonlight there's so
many different ways that they could go
with things i feel like this is one of
the best post-credit scenes that marvel
have ever put out it's the perfect way
to introduce jake take out harrow and it
also somewhat works as a standalone
thing where you could just see this as
an end however i demand more so give us
more foggy or i'm kicking off i'd of
course love to hear your thoughts so
make sure you comment below and let me
know your punk we're running a
competition right now and giving away
three copies of spider-man know a home
on the 15th of may and all you have to
do to be on the chance of winning is
like the video make sure you subscribe
with notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
the winners of the last one are on
screen right now so if that's you then
message me on twitter heavyspoilers if
you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
episode 6 which will be linked on screen
right now we've gone over the entire
thing from top to bottom so if you
enjoyed this video and want to know a
bit more then head over there right
after this if not then thanks for
sending through the video i've been paul
i'll see you next time take care peace